[Music]
brittany is with us brittany's in
manchester new hampshire hi brittany how
are you
hi good how are you thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i have watched both of you and dr
d
youtube channel um and my husband and i
just had not just we have a seven month
old baby
um and we're budgeting and doing all the
baby steps
um and we were having a hard time
i guess being a couple aside from like
parenting and
money so i was wondering how you
recommend like
not separating the two because there's
there really is no separation but just
we're kind of like roommates i guess but
that's going to explain it ah so is this
your first kid
yeah excellent so here i'm going to give
you a story and then i'll
i'll tell you what i would recommend you
do i remember sitting by a guy in grad
school
and i'd been married for a year or two i
was a terrible new husband i didn't know
what i was doing
and i was looking at him and he had been
married for a while and he had three or
four
kids and i said i don't know how that's
humanly possible and he gave me a line
that has stuck with me for 15 16 years
now
he said remember when you were single
and it was kind of awesome
i said yep and he said now you're
married
it's a different kind of awesome and
then he said i've got four
kids i don't sleep i don't have much
money in my account
but it's awesome it's a different kind
of awesome and that phrase is cheesy and
lame as it is a different kind of
awesome stuck with me
and so here's what i i notice couples
try to do is they try to
drag their dating life through their
first couple of years of marriage
they have a kid which is super
disruptive right
in all the good ways in bad ways and
you're seven months by the way
if you're not feeling like you will
never sleep again
if you are not everything doesn't make
sense right now i want you to know
you're exactly where you're supposed to
be
you actually did string your sentences
together i'm impressed that is super
impressive whatever meds you're taking
keep taking them because they're working
good but
that's awesome so they try to drag their
marriage before kid
into their new world and what i want you
to do i heard this
um this analogy given to to folks who
were coming back from any sort of
marital difficulties any sort of major
changes major moves
and here here it is they could never
take all the dust
and glass and metal and steel
that was the twin towers and collect it
all back and rebuild those things
after they fell it's different now right
and this is a beautiful thing not
not coming after you know an affair or
something like that but you're
they have to excavate everything and
rebuild something stronger
and beautiful and with sentiment and
with meaning
and so what you guys have to do is be
intentional about
building a new thing and it's already
got a great platform you already love
each other you're committed to each
other so you don't have to start from
scratch
but you have to re-envision what this is
going to look like and it's going to
take
more intentionality more hey we have to
put some stuff on the calendars that
used to come naturally to us
we used to be able to just run out and
go have fun and run to taco bell and
now we have to plan the taco bell run
for every other saturday and
fill in the blank right but i want you
good lord
please something else hold your baby
with someone else
you gotta practice how do you what how
do you get over the anxiety of leaving
your baby with somebody else
yeah you gotta practice yeah you gotta
practice and we're in the middle of a
pandemic and you've got a seven month
old
cut yourself some slack this is a weird
one you picked a weird moment in hips in
history to have a baby
right congratulations but you got to
practice yeah give yourself
uh so you know the way i delegate
anything in my life including people
things here in the business including
things like a babysitter
is i do not delegate to someone
particularly the care
of my new baby if it's especially my
first one because i'm scared about this
i'm anxious about this is
i delegate when i can trust someone's
competence
and their integrity and so i'm not
leaving a brand new baby when i leave
for the first time
with a 13 year old or someone you found
on a nap
or somebody that you you found on
craigslist okay
so first thing is like my mom will do it
and we also
trust her you can trust her competency
and her integrity because you're alive
don't beat yourself up over anxiety it's
normal right
it's it's and here's the thing you don't
have to go out for five days the first
time you got to go out for
an hour right yeah and you're going to
realize that everything's fine and good
and then when you come back your
mother's going to be happy and the
baby's going to be happy and you're
going to want to go out for another hour
[Laughter]
so just take a little short run with
somebody you trust a little bit longer
run
and you know by the time our youngest
came along
the oldest was watching them we were
anything anything to get out of that
right here that's right